a few years ago I started watching some
videos on social media and online of
guys slapping and I was into it
immediately
see what I'm looking for are the best
slap fighters in the world
powerslap and they'll be competing for a
spot in the first pay-per-view and
they'll also be fighting to be ranked so
for the coaches we brought in the two
best guys in the world
Darius the Destroyer is the heavyweight
champion from Missouri and this dude has
never lost a fight
beat his ass
uh you think so how did what are the
rules how does it work like is there
just like you just stand there what now
what if you get slapped first and then
you got to pull yourself together and be
the second slapper I hope he explains it
or is it like a like a challenge where
you staring each other down and see who
has the cajones to slap first I don't
know is it by time probably like when
you quit I love when they steal the
foreign TV show ideas like Ninja Warrior
you know American Ninja Warrior do you
remember when I used to watch like the
Japanese version when I was little yeah
yeah used to be like oh it was out there
first yeah it was in Japan first when we
had the little TV I used to watch it in
Japanese and then they finally made the
American version charge everything in
foreign languages you used to watch all
your Disney movies in Spanish too yeah I
don't know why I did that his
unconscious Darius
so the Wolverine's name is Ron and he's
a former MMA fighter turned slap fighter
thank you
another big shot from Wolverine oh my
this guy's got incredible power and
toughness they need to wear earplugs
because if you um you could Buster your
eardrum yeah it's a lot of pressure on
your ear it's like what the [__] like
air pressure wow it's like a plunger
yeah like a plunger this is wild I'm so
glad we were I could definitely we're
making a foray into the World of Sports
commentating yeah yeah incredible power
I'll be on the I'll be commentating the
Stanley Cup soon you know
and his only losses have been to the
Destroyer
their most recent fight was an epic
27. oh my God wait does that means
[__] that's crazy you know what you're
gonna say you know what you can see here
that you don't usually get to see in in
other fights is there's there's like
this Split Second after they get slapped
well you can see the emotion on their
face like this is personal this is like
when your mom slaps you in front of your
friends kind of a thing that's what I
don't know like if you just rewind it
and you look at this guy's expression
when he got slapped that's what it
looked like to me look at this guy
27 router yeah
oh look at this one that's crazy it was
eventually called in favor of Darius and
is considered by most people the
greatest slap fight ever
the champion oh so they're gonna train
these young up and coming Fighters and
then Darius and Ron are going to fight
live on pay-per-view for the first ever
heavyweight slap Championship so now I'm
going to sit down with the coaches and
the matchmakers and we're going to go
through film we're going to decide who
has to slap their way into the house and
who just goes straight in
Dana's really smart for getting into
this business
how did how did it start out now did he
have because now he
can then say I like this and
not the resources the team the knowledge
to do it all did he start out in a play
like with money and players no he was a
he was a Brokey he started UFC from like
nothing and now it's legit as big as
like NHL NBA all those yeah it's massive
it's probably a billionaire you know
Dana is a professional slap boxer too oh
no
what are your thoughts on this Dana
White was enjoying the night of the New
Year's Eve when he got in a heated
argument with his wife which eventually
turned into a public debate his drunken
wife slapped him first then in return
the intoxicated Dana also sorry why they
have to add the sound effects oh my God
okay well first of all there's no
context but
she slapped him so that's your take
there she slapped him first so he can
slap her back I mean it doesn't look
like he like beat this there's no [__]
out of it give her a slap that he would
give a man
I don't think a man should ever raise
his hands to his woman I think that he
could control her physically from
slapping him again very easily without
hitting her so I think it's you saw me I
didn't slap you back I think I'd give
you one of these um
what are you gonna do
see it's easy though he could have
subdued her from hitting him again
without hitting her so I don't think he
should have hit her I don't know the
context I don't know and and people will
say it doesn't matter the context he
shouldn't have done that and I say to
that no the context does matter because
we don't know what led up to that moment
and how much [__] he may have put up
with from her or how much [__] she may
have put up with from him before it got
physical
one
two
all right so did you notice I'm looking
at technique here so there's like this
is just like throwing a punch like he's
putting his whole body into it show it
again
something one
two look at the hips the hips oh yeah
that's what I'm about declaring the
winner
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm excited I'm excited sorry do you
think you think you have to get your
hands callous like you should be out
doing manual labor moving bricks
bare-handed so that they get good in
callous you don't have a little that
like mad nerve ending when you slap
something probably you know what little
lady Elena hands lady Elena hands these
are not off these are the hands of a
woman that works that cooks and cleans
and chases after her darling child
you're for legacy I want to prove that
I'm the baddest man in the world
you're watching me wow
[Music]
for your winner by unanimous decision
I think there is have you seen like the
other Russian ones like they put them in
a telephone booth and they just go to
town There's Crazy Ones the one-eyed
wolf could not get medically cleared so
Ryan Phillips is going straight into the
house
my DJ freaks out
this guy looks certified out of his mind
I'm all right though
this is
so fun to watch
the fight around oh he cannot continue
oh we want to give these guys another
opportunity so they're going to have to
slap their way into the house my
nickname is the Iron Giant so it said if
gets if you get cut you can't continue I
mean how the hell are you going to keep
taking slaps like that why why no no
when you get cut in a boxing match or an
MMA fight again you you just it's
different look you tough it up no I hate
2020.3 whatever this is 20 20 23 what's
wrong no 21st century because oh you're
bleeding we've got to stop it's a fight
God how far we've come from the days of
the Roman Coliseum where they threw men
in with lions you can't even do a
push-up who are you going off about all
this
maybe in a past life I was watching the
fights in the Roman Coliseum all right
the fighter has that laceration in his
lip and he cannot continue oh that's a
big cut can you this February we're
partnering up with a Navy SEAL friend of
ours Tom Shea hosts a 21 day virtual
event that you guys can join with us Tom
is gonna teach you how to listen to your
mind in a new way and how to control it
so that you can have the discipline you
need to build the life you want whether
it's working out your relationships your
money your spiritual growth this is a 21
day virtual event where you get to learn
how to kill the excuses in your head and
you get to learn some discipline and
those are things that's how successful
people get successful best part is when
you come in through us you get a
discount on the enrollment so use code
Sunny fast50 to get 50 off the event you
will not regret it you will be a changed
person at the end of it do not miss this
so if you're interested becoming a
reformed human an absolute animal go to
tomshay.com and use Sunny fast50 for 50
off of this program we're we want to
give these guys another opportunity so
they're going to have to slap their way
into the house my nickname is the Iron
Giant and I'm excited to Showcase my
power
it's over oh
do not get up it's over I knew it was
gonna be a knockout from the start I
could have hit a lot harder but it
didn't even matter if you did not get
back up so it's a great feeling what
you're gonna see from me is straight
vicious
oh my God
this is insane three
oh my God this dude this dude saw Jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
we might get this opportunity only once
so I don't think I'm going to hold back
that knockout is one of the craziest
Knockouts I've ever seen we aren't
having female fighters of this first
Power slap competition but Darius was so
impressed by Sheena that he's gonna have
her come on board as his assistant coach
for the season and I love that idea
Wesley versus John Wesley is so tough
man
this guy had a hematoma on his cheek bit
down fought through it
this dude's awesome and we're very
excited to have him here the winner
Wesley
[Applause]
oh my God what is up with his face he's
done so much in my life where I'm just
driving for this stream this is my dream
oh my God look at this guy I want to
change the world
good power
you see that one
yeah good power oh that's got to be the
worst feeling when you know you you hit
like just fingertips and you whiffed and
you're like oh I got it over his face is
it powder chalk so he did get he didn't
get fingertips I don't know how he could
have been just multiple rounds these two
are slapping out of each other
foreign David that's what I'm talking
about
[Music]
Vern is probably one of the hardest
hitting guys
can we go to Vegas World slap um that'd
be that'd be dope plan on being on the
top this is going to be the most
exciting the most interesting and the
most unique sport I've ever seen in your
life you tune in you're going to see
just why you're gonna love it what we
need over the next several weeks is your
expertise and to turn these guys into
Killers any combat sport you always have
a handful of holy moments this is a
whole nother level
when when is when is the one of the live
competitions we gotta go Mom what are
you reading the screen no it's on TV
Wednesday's on TBS I don't want to say I
didn't say let's sit in the living room
and watch this I I'm saying let's go to
Vegas and see it live that would be dope
I'll look into it all right you gotta
who wants to meet us in Vegas let's do
this oh yeah I am pumped up now I that
just woke me all the way up you ever
been slapped in a fight or at all yeah
there was one time we were at my
friend's house and he was sleeping so I
um we all Drew in his face and I was the
last one to draw on his face and he saw
me doing or no I I drew at fast dog like
my fortnite username on his forehead and
so when he woke up and looked in the
mirror he saw that and he came out and
just like a blind rage and just let one
go at me like I wasn't even looking at
him but but doesn't it take a different
emotional toll than a punch because yeah
no oh that that might have been a punch
I don't know it was wasn't very sure uh
base grandma hardcore slapped me in
front of one of my friends once I was in
my room and she came in and I I said
something to her that was probably a
little fresh but probably not that fresh
because I remember being I think and she
overreacted and she just hauled off and
slapped me right across the face and my
friend was like and I I was mortified
and I'm sure I cried but I tried not to
cry because I also didn't want to cry in
front of my friend but it stung mentally
like physically and emotionally these
guys are you know they're tougher than
you know a 10 year old girl for sure or
but getting slapped man it ain't easy to
take so I got to give it to these guys
and I definitely want to go see this
live all right thank you guys so much
for watching make sure to like subscribe
follow me on Instagram at sunnyfaz at
Sunny's mother for me thanks guys this
is really fun
[Music]